choking on smoke with only a hose to
protect her India McDonald faced
Australia's wildfires head-on with her
father Sean they fought for five hours
saving their house cars and garden in
rural Victoria the professionals are
struggling - thousands of firefighters
are battling to contain the wildfires
scorching the states of Victoria and New
South Wales an area home to more than 13
million people with once the front here
the wind just picked up and embers just
took off and that was it
everything with them just went wolf it
was always going to come one day and the
conditions now draw everywhere you know
I've got no chance no water
international help is arriving by this
weekend the US will have seemed to
nearly 100 firefighters Canada has sent
more than 60 the Australian military is
using planes and helicopters to douse
flames while preparing for possible
evacuations on the ground police are
trying to keep people out of fire zones
areas that grow and change suddenly with
the wind looks like it's jump the
highway up west of us and it's just
roared down like a bloody freight train
and it's actually cut through and it's
sub Lee's come through what are you up
north now thousands of residents along
the East Coast have been pushed to the
water's edge if not in it the fire is
along the beach
[Applause]
in sydney the mayor was determined the
show must go on for the new year the
spectacle was granted an exemption to a
statewide fireworks ban despite a
petition signed by nearly 300,000 people
calling for them to be cancelled it is
the most beautiful place in the world to
celebrate New Years Eve and that's why
people say it's on their bucket list
they want to come to Australia to do
that it does put us on on the
international calendar and it is a
really important for the economy the
cost of this bushfire crisis is yet to
be quantified more than 1,000 homes and
thousands of hectares of farmland
destroyed and with it animals the
University of Sydney estimating nearly
half a billion had been killed
we are absolutely stretched right across
New South Wales we've got fires burning
from the Queensland border all the way
down to the Victorian border across the
Great Dividing range in the heat of
summer as you to arrive
Charlotte Bella's al-jazeera